[Inaudible].
Guys, Jared, here with another blog.
Have you ever sensed that a movie video game or TV show was deliberately
punishing you by making you the butt of the joke?
Has it ever felt like an artist's work amounted to a big old Loogi in your face?
And have you ever actually.
I really enjoyed it. Thank you, sir.
A particularly ballsy creator to troll their own audience and a particularly
talented one to pull it off,
whether it's the Cohen brothers robbing us of a satisfying ending or South
parks, Trey Parker,
making us sit through a Halloween special that he knew only he would like.
Did everyone enjoy the Halloween special? No, Randy only you did.
Oh, well that was pretty much my target audience.
There seems to be a certain kind of creator who derives joy from trolling their
audience sometimes just for the LOLs. And sometimes to make a profound point,
I've always been pretty captivated by the sheer gall.
It takes to purposely disappoint your viewers,
but there's one particular example of trolling in film. That's so audacious.
So legendary.
So utterly fascinating that it left me with my mouth agape after I saw it.
And I thought it deserved a closer look. So join me in this wisecrack blog.
As I detailed my pick for the greatest troll in cinema history.
And.
As always spoilers ahead,
before we can discuss what constitutes a truly excellent troll,
we first need to establish what does it even mean to troll your audience?
In this context,
trolling broadly means deliberately angering someone to get a reaction from
them. For the purposes of this video,
I'm using the word to refer to that experience.
When a piece of media builds a certain understanding between creator and
audience only to aggressively undercut that understanding with full knowledge
that doing so will upset the viewer. For example,
consider the legendary release of metal gear solid to for years,
fans were teased with images that implied we'd be playing as the franchise's
beloved hero, turns out an hour into the game, solid snake soft,
and you have to play the rest of the game as some rando,
but all the world's media trolling seems utterly banal.
When compared to that of the 1999, Japanese film, dead or alive,
directed by Takashi meet gay. If you haven't seen it. No worries.
I'll fill in the details. Now Takashi Mika is in my opinion,
something of an ecentric genius. He makes multiple movies a year,
sometimes as many as five while straddling vastly different genres and
tones. He's made everything from Ninja action movies to fantasy dramas,
to surreal gangster flicks, to kids' movies,
to some of the most uncategorizable inexplicably, bizarre you've ever seen.
He's always pushing boundaries and refuses to let anything get in the way of him
making an exciting movie, even the script,
which he has been known to elaborate on substantially.
So how exactly does Mika troll his audience for context?
Here's a brief recap of dead or alive.
The film depicts two tortured souls caught in the midst of a power dispute
between the triads and the Yakuza in Japan Shinjuku district.
Our protagonists are Joe Jima and Ryo ichi.
Joe Gemma is a policeman who is forced to do business with criminals in order to
fund an emergency medical procedure for his daughter, Ryan Ricci,
born to Japanese parents in China is a Hitman who uses blood money to send his
little brother Tojo to an American college. But despite their sacrifices,
Joe Juma and Riley cheek can't seem to hold their families together.
Despite [inaudible] efforts to keep him from a life of violence.
Togi is tragically killed in a gunfight.
Similarly Joe Gemma's efforts and poorly,
even after he acquires the money for the procedure,
his family dynamic remains strained their tragic fates collide.
When Ryan beachy discovers that Joe Gemma is awarding his plans to take over
drug shipments from Taiwan, Ryan leechy then kills Joe Gemma's entire family.
The movie ends with the familiar gangster film scenario,
a standoff between two men with nothing to lose.
How will this tragic cycle of violence end for these two bereaved family men
glad you asked Joe Gemma holds a bazooka out of his back
And Riley leechy pulls a glowing orb out of his chest.
The two projectiles.
Collide and the earth explodes VN.
What just happened?
The audience has spent nearly two hours investing in these characters,
identifying what their struggles and engaging with the moral ambiguity is at
play only for the movie to at the last minute change genres entirely
and descend into trippy Saifai craziness for comparison.
Imagine if at the end of Titanic, right as Rose lets go of Jack,
he turns into a lizard person,
eats her and throws the Titanic into the sun and ending that broke the tone.
So thoroughly would kind of ruin all that King of the world stuff. Right?
When I saw this movie for the first time,
I felt like the joke was on me for caring about the story.
So what in the world is going on here? Is it just pure nihilism,
a devious filmmaker getting his rocks off by pulling the rug out from under his
audience? Or is there something deeper at play to figure this out?
We're going to have to take a close look at the rest of the film.
First I have to mention the intro.
It would be misleading for me to see that the entire film is devoid of us.
And tricities because the first eight minutes are also totally bonkers though,
in a way that stays firmly rooted in the modern Yakuza film sub genre to say
it's not YouTube friendly is an absurd understatement.
It's eight minutes of exhilarating, no holds barred, brutally tasteless,
deranged, excess sex, strippers, hard drugs, binge eating murder,
all in highly stylized hyperkinetic editing set to heavy rock and roll.
[Inaudible].
It's generally some of the most violent into praise stuff you've ever seen me.
Gay claims that this intro was initially comprised of a whopping 20 separate
establishing scenes that he decided to condense into a single wild one as
writers,
Rob Daniel and Dave would explain in their essay from the anthology Bureau
without frontiers horror cinema across the globe.
This choice importantly demonstrates his belief that a film script is merely the
starting point.
But after that whiplash of pure sleaze that are alive slows way,
the hell down and proceeds to conform to all the genre conventions of a typical
gangster film. This continues for the vast majority of its runtime.
The scenes are typically grounded in realism, family dynamics and emotion,
the film transitions to lethargic wide shots and introspective meditations on
the nature of evil.
But unsafe.
Sequences. The camera goes handheld for a more immersive feel,
but unlike the intro or the ending, it remains grounded in realism.
For the most part,
the film leans heavily into what Daniel and would describe as the philosophical
and introspective calm of traditional Japanese filmmaking,
a kind of calm that makes the ending all the more out of place,
but we'll get to that what's more dead or alive.
Presents us with a number of moral ambiguity is common to the genre.
Joe Gemma's need to engage in criminal activity to afford his daughter's surgery
and Riley cheese violence enabling his brother's education.
It also explores cultural issues, specifically the plight of the Zen,
where you Koji or people of Japanese parentage born in China after world war II,
Riley chia and his gang are strangers in a strange land seeking roots and an
identity in the midst of a gang war between the Japanese and the Chinese,
neither of which accept them. But despite all this effective,
if standard Yakuza movie fare every once in a while for very brief moments,
the film breaks genre conventions and goes a little haywire and it's in those
moments that could clue us in to what the ending may signify periodically.
We'll witness scenes dramatize in a bland traditional manner,
perhaps even redundantly. So only to spontaneously erupt into hyper violence.
That explosion seemed a bit over the top. No,
likewise from [inaudible] kills the triad and your cous, uh,
leaders and entire act of traditional filmmaking is upset when the editing style
and level of violence reverts back to the style of the intro.
Sometimes these explosions of access or funny other times disturbing and other
times make for bizarre moments of levity.
This tendency to indulge in bizarre rhythmic switches from banal to extremely
comedic racist.
The question is this whole film and elaborately constructed dark comedy.
And if so, what's the joke. Let's go back to the ending,
which aside from the world blowing up also involves a guy jumping at Joe Gemma's
car with a grenade in his hand,
causing it to inexplicably explode hundreds of feet in the air.
Joe Gemma of course survives this.
Somehow the original ending written in the script featured our two protagonists
meeting in Taiwan where they would have a final dramatic shootout.
And ultimately the audience wouldn't know who won this ending.
Presumably didn't excite me K. So he changed it,
but it's worth asking what a slow motion shootout be any more meaningful than
the ending we got,
whether it's two bodies lying dead in the street or the entire planet exploding
either way.
The narrative device that brings the film to a close is like most films of the
Yakuza genre violence. Now consider the central plot points.
[inaudible] brother dies in a gunfight and Joe Gemma's family has killed as
collateral damage for his meddling and Ryo cheese affairs is this bizarre ending
commenting on the violence that dominates the genre of Yakuza movies that
violence just begets more violence.
Perhaps Mika is criticizing the enormously popular gangster film genre,
or by first inhabiting it and then perverting it,
it takes the supposition that violence is in itself,
a meaningful way to end the movie and draws it out to its logical conclusion.
That's such violent ways of life have potentially negative implications on the
whole world. Of course,
it'd be remiss of me not to mention how absolutely hilarious this moment is.
After the initial shock wears off as if the film is making fun of the ambiguous.
Everybody dies conclusion by intensifying it to an utterly insane degree.
Now it's worth noting that Mika has made a number of Yakuza films,
not all of which have this arguably critical edge.
So it's also possible that this improvised ending is more result of boredom with
the genre than disdain for it. There are many other ways to theorize.
This ending may be me K's railing against the restrictions that any genre film
imposes on the audience's expectations.
Perhaps the ending is a wake-up call for gangster film fans to engage more
critically with the subject matter.
Or maybe this abrasive change in tone is more commentary on the limitations
faced by directors when making genre films, limitations,
which can stifle them with narrowly defined tropes and conventions either way.
I don't think this troll fits under the category of purely spitting in the
audience's face as taken aback as I was by the ending.
This bizarro turn is decisively as thought provoking as it is hilarious,
but I'm curious to hear what you guys think.
Does the movie draw the audience in with common images of the Yakuza film genre
only to punish us for being seduced by something so trite and excessively
violent?
Is it depriving us of the satisfying sensical ending we perhaps wanted or asking
us if such an ending would really make any more sense or is this Epic troll
purely nihilistic.
And can you think of any examples of truly cinema that outdo Mika?
Let me know what you guys think in the comments.
Thanks to all our awesome patrons who support the channel and our podcasts.
Don't forget to smash that subscribe button and I'll see you next time guys.
Peace.
[Inaudible].